this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is going to be
taking a look at a highly requested game
of yours destiny 2. and boy does he have
some thoughts on bungie's weapon design
oh lord right
pause there
yikes this is looking a bit like a an
archetypal cursed gun to me if there are
any other games guns and mechanics that
you guys want to see jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
and make sure to subscribe as well as
we've got tons of content just like this
on the channel including loadout a show
where we take a look at the history and
impact of some of the most iconic
weapons in gaming but without further
ado let's take a look at the guns of
destiny 2.
i like the design of this i have to say
it's looking very much like what's a
mishmash it's got some chiappa rhino in
there with a barrel that's in line with
the bottom chamber in the cylinder so
the idea is there for to help control
recoil same for the
faceted cylinder it's not the only
design with one of those but and the
logic there is just to keep the gun
narrower however
the way this works is a bit weird in
respect of that
faceted cylinder because they've gone
for a quirky reload we've got a swing
out cylinder on a crane or a yoke but
rather than rather than the cases being
pushed out or falling out and fresh
rounds being put in we've got a
reloadable cylinder inside a cylinder
insert exhibit meme here which which is
you know okay fair enough but why though
uh because you're you're
reducing
the capacity of the cylinder you'd fit
fewer rounds in now this is i'm not
familiar with with the technical law of
this game i may well discover that
there's a reason for this but if we're
assuming conventional cartridges here or
even caseless ammunition you want to use
the maximum real estate of that round
cylinder or in this case flattened off
but the inside is round you don't want
to compromise that by making a
reloadable unit
that is smaller we've got 13 rounds in
this thing now if you if you visualize a
revolver cylinder for 13 rounds
it's gonna be about that i would say
makes sense that you'd have to come up
with a new sci-fi feed system for this
thing but i don't i don't think they've
stuck the landing with that because it
doesn't seem to make any sense to me if
this was some sort of energy weapon sure
but this is this is definitively a
projectile weapon however the
ammunition's supposed to work there
ain't enough space
in that unit
right this this game is really taxing my
my brain which is probably an indicator
that i should switch it off so we've got
this thing and it's obviously a spin on
the old west lever action rifle but it's
so complicated uh it's got a spiral
fluted bolt which someone has obviously
seen on like a high-end bolt action or
something and has incorporated that
because it looks cool doesn't really
make much sense on this and we've got
the
john browning
bolt system that's in the winchester
1892 for example rather than the classic
toggle action it's not quite the
browning action but it does have the
bolt that protrudes out the back uh to
[ __ ] the hammer so there's some
mechanical functionality going on there
and we can see the rounds conventional
looking they look almost like five point
steel cased 5.56 millimeter rounds
interestingly and they are held on a
leather
shell holder that is part of or so
strapped to this very elaborate wooden
stock i'd have to say i like the overall
design um the sort of black and gold and
the dark wood it actually looks pretty
good to me it's just very busy compared
to a real gun and the the cartridges
being held opposing each other rather
than go all going the same way would
make quick
loading a bit awkward and mechanically i
can't really figure out how it's feeding
those rounds there's there's a tube
below the barrel that would normally be
the magazine but it looks too short and
not kind of connected up
to the mechanism in a way that would
work
okay in trying to figure out if this
thing is mechanically viable i have
spotted
a weird quirk of the iron sights so it
does have iron signs as you can see
looks like it has several it's got a
it's got a groove in what looks like a
lot like a conventional
tangent sight but it has the ramps for
the tangent on top of the tangent so
it's got design elements of a real rifle
sight but they're upside down and then
this is so you could use the the groove
the notch in the back of that as your
sight then there's a sort of
gold-colored horseshoe
thing that looks like it could be a rear
sight and then there's a flip up front
sight
with a round protector and a gold post
sitting behind that
and i can't see how that would even flip
up to act as a rear sight and it isn't a
rear sight because it's a post
this really makes my brain hurt i think
all of that is just included because it
looks busy and interesting but it
doesn't make a lick of sense as far as i
can tell
we've certainly got some visually
striking weapon designs in this game
that's for sure so we've got a shotgun
but it's got a very elaborate
semi-pistol grip thumb hole stock some
kind of weird energy system installed in
the butt and there's what looks almost
like a cylinder with a sort of gold
lattice arrangement with more energy
contained within it but then we've got
some some sort of elaborate
feed mechanism with some pulls and
doickies and what looks almost like a
cylinder so i wonder if this is going to
be a revolver shotgun you've got cooling
holes
that look like they're in the barrel
not in a jacket so let's and there's a
cable some sort of cable actuated system
or a rod i don't know like a wire
running across the top another
completely wacky gun let's see what it
does
this is a really obvious thing to say
but um a very
gamey idea for a gun either
the character is
off camera manipulating some kind of
mode switch or something or it's just
magic and aiming down sights gives you a
single shot and hip firing gives you
shotgun which is interesting in terms of
gameplay in that you'd normally have
either a spread of shots that's
devastating up close and terrible at
range you know the the video game trope
or like one shot that's reasonably
powerful giving giving the player both
in one weapon is an interesting idea i
don't know how that shakes out in terms
of gameplay
and then when the gun breaks open fort
is a break open gun we see
eight rounds in an intriguing
arrangement
four and then four on the outside of
that sort of weird geometric pattern but
of course we don't have eight barrels we
have one barrel so it's almost like
they're funneling down and then
as i say somehow you're selecting
whether you fire one of them or is it
all of them into one point of aim don't
know or whether you're firing all of
them slash inner spread all of which i
could probably live with if this was
some magic future ammunition and weapon
system that i just can't get my head
around because it's you know i'm a 21st
century person but these rounds look
totally conventional you know standard
brass case rounds percussion primers in
the in the base and they are somehow
working with this magical gun to achieve
the effect that we just talked about so
it's another kind of mind blower
unfortunately for me
oh lord right
pause there
yikes
this is looking a bit like a an
archetypal cursed gun to me yeah i don't
really know what we've got
i was going to say we've got two barrels
and then two more barrels kind of held
on with with a very large sort of
circlip plumbing piece of kit and
there's another one wrapped around the
center but i'm increasingly unsure what
they're holding on because those things
seem to be no i'm gonna go with the
additional two barrels at the bottom
are actually being held on as as
upgrades of some sort although i don't
imagine that there are upgrades you add
in the game this is this is clearly
meant to be the art design for this gun
and then we've got a sort of over
engineered looking buttstock and a tiny
magazine
that looks like i can see the rounds in
the front of it they go all the way to
the bottom and there's no spring visible
to actually feed them up but hey it's
the future maybe they're magnetically
fed don't know let's see what this thing
does because it's not making a huge
amount of sense to me
this thing is nuts so
so we've got our our single magazine
feeding one primary barrel that works
like a slow firing sort of assault rifle
thing and then the other barrels
appear to be completely random and then
the character is slapping the side of
the gun which changes the setting and
and your pattern of shot effectively
giving you sort of a pseudo shotgun
effect not seen this before as you can
probably tell just
trying to
trying to think how it might work in
in real life it's just not working is it
there's no way
that uh additional barrels strapped onto
a gun there's no way to get rounds into
those i'm either missing something or
it's more space magic okay i'm gonna
need to address the name of this thing
which i've only just found out so it's
called cerberus plus one so i could only
imagine someone came up with a concept
for a three-barreled gun as in like the
three-headed town that guards the gates
of hell in mythology and then someone
said wouldn't it be funny if we put
another barrel on it and called it
cirrus plus one thus completely
undermining the whole
concept of the name i don't know whether
to be disappointed or proud about that
wow this is especially wacky looking uh
luckily i have the information here to
tell me what this is so the the
yellow horn i'm gonna i'm gonna go with
rocket launcher i'm glad they told me
it's a rocket launcher i may not have
figured that out so that does have a
huge barrel or is that a barrel it has
fins on it normally things with fins fly
so i look forward to seeing whether
that's the warhead and the whole thing
flies out in which case i'm not sure
those fins on the front are going to do
much but anyway just weirdly this
reminds me of some of our combination
weapons at the royal armouries um we
don't have anything that looks like this
but we have
crazy attempts from throughout history
where people have tried to make a
boarding pike that's also got guns on it
or
an axe that's also got five guns buried
in it with different mechanisms crazy
stuff like that and this thing strikes
me as more than anything else similar to
that looks like something from a culture
where weapons are more than just weapons
the lump on the side turns out to be an
optic fine it's a clearly like a lock-on
some sort of lock-on before launch
system
there are little animal heads arranged
around the ocular lens which seems like
a really poor idea because you're gonna
be distracted by those never mind the
fact that it's gonna make the weapon
cost a hell of a lot more than it needs
to the fins on the front of
the tube at the front that's the barrel
so the fins are purely decorative the
mechanism itself pops up at the back
and we load a munition into
some sort of feed device which then
falls back into the gun and you launch
your rocket slash missile because it's
called a rocket launcher but see i
suspect that there's a dom fire option
and a tracking option
which would make it a guided missile
launcher not a rocket launcher if we
want to get all technical about it
so this is the same revolver broadly as
the one that i
first saw same design
basically speaking it's got some
differences in lines um differences in
decoration it has a different cylinder
with an interesting arrow
symbol on it it's like a i guess a rare
version of
that
standard revolver from the game it's
what i'm trying to get at its main
feature is that you can fan it
so if you're not familiar with that you
need to watch some westerns and it's the
case of you hold down the trigger so
you're essentially just disengaging the
trigger ahead of time and then you are
pulling back the hammer and letting it
go it's a really bad idea it doesn't
work as a tactic did it first appear in
movies or did it develop in cowboy
became cowboy action shooting where
people try to find the most efficient
ways to use old weapons on the clock
against targets and you do find that you
know they they're able to run
winchesters much much faster than they
would have ever done in originally just
by sheer skill and maybe a wrap around
the lever so you don't destroy off your
fingers and um one of the early skills
that was learned more for kind of
exhibition choosing i think
was funny
yeah so as expected as it said on the
tin effectively uh you are fanning the
revolver so
conceptually it's not full auto because
you are manually operating the gun every
time you
slap the hammer with the trigger held
down but as far as gameplay goes yeah
it's full auto because the firing
cycle is automated and you don't have to
keep clicking or pressing a trigger so
in game terms it's fully auto in
firearms terms it's still manually
operated you're just firing it manually
as fast as possible although the rate of
fire achieved here is actually
significantly lower than what some of
the cowboy action guys can do when they
fan their hammers so have a look for
some videos of that because it's really
quite impressive what what they can do
it's not something that was done
historically but it is physically
possible it's also really bad for your
gun so don't do it of course that makes
very little sense in this context
because the the conventional version of
the revolver has a non-functional hammer
you just pull the trigger as fast as you
want in theory the only limitation is
the
recoil
waiting for the sights to come back down
or the game limiting you from from
clicking again and then we somehow pivot
to a hammer that does work and is how
you are making the gun faster doesn't
quite make sense but it is based on this
real technique of fanning
thank you for watching guys that was the
guns of destiny 2 which is a bit of an
ordeal for someone like me who's his
head is in the realistic firearms uh
most days some interesting designs
definitely you can enjoy our own
armouries channel if you'd like to here
on youtube uh we've got various social
media outlets as well facebook instagram
twitter if you really would like to we
have a donation scheme and there's a
link to that in the description either
way i'll see you guys again next time
[Music]
you